hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sims 4 now I played
this a while ago and in it I made a
mockery of Bob waiting myself and this
time I'm gonna do exactly the same thing
over and over and over again I'm gonna
make Bob wait and I live in a house
together
of total and other crap and the reason
I'm playing this again
oh crap oh I forgot Oh reinstall dit Oh
No okay so I'm gonna give myself five
minutes to recreate Bob waiting myself
and I don't know how well this is gonna
go but I'm gonna give it a go I guess
you could start with myself oh no I
guess that sounds like Wade okay Wade's
a party animal who is gloopy gloomy oh I
remember
gloomy goofball and completely insane I
totally forgot about it so he insane oh
god I don't have long I got to make him
how do I make him that's right I gotta
do this okay uh oh God hey calm down
there wait I forgot how to do ah that's
the one
scheisse ah got to make the face more
yep that's it yep a little more like
that okay not so handsome uh eyes
collect at will farther apart little
higher up eyebrow together
big nose Oh skinny face I seen a little
- not crazy that's right that's right
little weighty
that's right way deep ooh oh that's
right who's a who's not so pretty Jesus
okay gotta get the smile up in there
he's so happy he's happy about
everything that I'm doing to him
get this out here get this open more
open more open less less chin cheese I'm
running out of time I've got no time how
do I make him bigger how do i am big
innate him how do I make him in big
innate it there there we go I forgot
about that oh no oh no wait what have I
done
I'm gonna need more than five minutes to
do this cuz whoa whoa hey yeah maybe a
little thinner on the face there we go
narrow hips he's got like no hips thin
chicken thighs tiny feet
let's narrow the shoulders up to that he
looks like a freaking alien let's see
but that was it I remember now
he was blue he had a bit more chest yeah
was it looks weird it was ready in the
blood ha ha I totally had forgotten
about weed and then he then he walked he
had a certain walk that was right uh
this was it sluggish yeah he now has a
beard so oh wait I'm not sorry not at
all not at all ok gotta make another one
now for Bob let's see at alien Wang Zi
hua ji Zhou God ah hey get rid of it huh
get rid of it I don't know when they
added that holy crap holy crap people
made me ha ha look at me oh damn I'm not
gonna use them but whatever Beyonce and
markiplier
for summary oh ho ho I like that
markiplier I might use that Lacey let me
see it Bob's in here it's Bob waiting
Jack hey I'm not gonna use it
I just curious ok alright whoa no no no
hang on no no yes no yes
hmm ha ha I wonder how horrible I look
there's nothing like Bob oh i remember
bob was upset but bob was a little sad
that he had to live with us losers oh my
God where have I gone so wrong oh yeah
now I remember what Bob looks like oh
it's all coming together now okay let's
put the face in there let's get the chin
out that's pretty close to it mm-hmm
getting there getting there what have I
done to his face I want to go on the
record and saying this is not what Bob
looks like at all and I tried my best
but it just didn't work so
no one can blame me no one can blame me
at all
he has earrings for some reason don't no
one can blame me no one can blame me for
anything no one can blame me baba tries
Baba truck at red bump that's ride I
really tried I didn't try that hard
actually yeah I can't believe that Bob
woo-hoo-hoo-hoo
he's a chief of mischief wait what did I
make wait what did wait what is what I
wait I want way to be the chief of
mischief cuz he always messing with us
and Bob oh that's right Bob uh uh
burgers
Wade is Wade
wombo he is a bro no no God no no don't
do that cheerful no he's always like the
[ __ ] you guys do
he's geek and he's a snob got it that's
exactly what Bob would do probably not
sorry Bob yeah I am NOT a woman I'm not
oh yeah pop what so he's tired of our
[ __ ] that's right ah that's that's
that's not quite me but I'm running out
of time I gotta go for I gotta add from
the database this one's really nice this
one's thank you kick a doll Beck I'm
gonna steal it see uh merge yeah yeah
now we're talking now we're talking
ooh bodybuilder change that hair up I
haven't had that hair for a long time oh
I love it I love it I love it so much oh
it's pink - pink - yes yes I love this I
love everything about this oh yeah I
skipped leg day that's my problem
but I didn't get foot day oh yes now do
we got the booty how definitely he do
it's so smooth it's so
dude yeah I know what I got going on I
know I know it oh it's it's a thing of
beauty it's a thing of beauty it's a
thing of beauty
okay so we got Wade we got Bob's Burgers
and we got mark and plier it's so
perfect
okay yeah we did it ray the wombo family
yeah whatever
if something was bothering me about this
it's it's it's not quite perfect hang on
there there we go
that's more like it I just wanted a
little more puppy dog in there
mmm-mmm-mmm he's so cute
Yuki do qyz dead out there as far as
possible
my strong jaw oh my god from the front
it looks not totally abnormal and then
when you go fro my god that's horrifying
okay I'm done
okay I did it I got what I wanted Oh
Steve pliers wait what are you doing in
that outfit that's not your outfit keep
that outfit on what do you think you're
doing full body yeah bottoms nothing oh
oh I can change it up ha ha I almost I
really like this one I really like it
I really like it especially with the
bunny slippers I need some change
little tiny itty oh my god his arms are
sticks ah they're just tiny itty bitty
sticks oh god damn it Wade you better
wear your costume or else okay we did it
that only took 25 minutes ah damn it
okay all right all right okay
no I know everything oh there are
there's new blazes ooh we could go to
Mongolia Magnolia promenade I don't know
if we could live in Magnolia promenade
the applier household is but how much is
this one ooh three thousand it's so easy
okay we're gonna move we're gonna move
dude this is exactly what we didn't last
one oh it's not gonna go well oh man I
have so much fun just making him oh it's
so fun no I don't need to see dicot it
oh god damn it Wade change your goddamn
clothes there you go that's the stuff
okay we need to build the house that's
what we got to do the first thing no why
is Wade the head of this goddamn
household I've never wanted this to be
this way okay so if that's a front door
we need to put this right here we can't
build too big what we did last time is
we built too big and it was it was it
was out of our price range so we need to
remember that we always need to be
manageable about our expectations so I'm
gonna build us a very manageable house
and that's it that's our house all right
I gotta gumdrops okay not the bathroom
door whoo
that one's cheap and it looks cool I
like it why is this like a dungeon door
I'm not entirely sure but hey whatever
we're living on a budget we can't
exactly be blowing all our money on
important things like things garden cut
love it okay
we leech distribute our things okay
those are that's Bob and Wade's bed and
then my bed will be this one much better
much better I'm not gonna live in
squalor like that what do you think I'm
a loser like them there's no way that
gives everyone enough space to get in
their beds and sleep in the same room
cuz we're cool like that very close very
close i I kind of forgot to put our
relation to each other so I'm not
entirely sure what we are do if we're
brothers or family I'm I'm not I'm not
certain we have different last names
okay so what we need is we need a fridge
what that's not what I want
there we go cheap cheap as dirt and ass
ugly in color literally the worst color
we could or pink now literally the worst
color [ __ ] Brown that's what we've
always wanted
we need a window or something probably
stop putting the expensive stuff let's
see uninspiring window okay cool I like
this it's good uh we'll just put that
over my bed so that I can actually get
something right there that's good I like
that
how about two for me I love that okay
and then one light box by the door
and that's all we get that's all we need
we need nothing else okay so now we got
to go to the kitchen probably this one
ugly love it love it
stylish nah not really but ugly yeah
ugly okay this one what kind of colors
we got where's my turd Brown where's my
horrifically ugly bland coke
contemporary counter I like it but
where's my ugly colors Bad's Dario good
enough all right and uh I don't think we
actually need safety uh cabinets don't
we need the cabinet I don't even know if
we're gonna be able to reach that I
don't know what that's gonna do for us
I've never even seen that before okay we
need some place to sit okay so we need
something that everyone is gonna be able
to use no one's gonna be able to fight
over so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
put a spinning barstool in the very
center of the entire house and that'll
be our chair so then we'll actually not
be able to fight over anything we'll
actually be able to know what we're
supposed to do and then we take the
trash can
I like this one boink done and we need
some lights lights oh we need to toilet
okay all right you know what I changed
my mind about that stool who needs who
needs a stool when you got the world's
greatest uh [ __ ] when you got the
world's greatest stool right smack dab
in the middle of the house done we got
it okay cool and then the shower bucket
will be right who needs to shower we
don't need a shower we could wash our
hands and the sink that's not there [ __ ]
put the trash can right right right by
the toilet where it's needed the moat
most right right behind it put the trash
right by Wade bed cuz why not it's not a
kitchen sink but close enough oh it
could be [ __ ] it could be turd green I
love turd green that's a lot of new
lights almost too many okay uh whatever
this kids walls cuz Wade is scared at
night put one right by the bathroom
boink okay and then one above each bed
okay I think we did it I think that's
everything that a person needs I guess
we do need a shower maybe could just
wash our hands until we get clean you
know maybe maybe I'll do that we're on a
budget here we don't really have you
know everything we need maybe a bathtub
I'll go with a bathtub my secret spot
tub I don't know if it's so much of a
secret if it's gotta be at the middle of
house
today's six itself it's is stuff a stub
will ever know your dick a bath done
perfect I guess we need a TV but I guess
the the the toilet would be perfect
viewing experience for the TV see let's
go we're stupid ass bout bachelors so we
wall mount our TV goddamn we got a wall
method really low cuz the stupid lights
in the way
oh good enough oh good enough oh good
glad we blew our budget on that okay I
think we're good we're good guys we did
it we got everything a person needs
close enough anyway all right we did it
it's the applier family and we are so
happy about our lives I can't wait to
start living and experiencing the
horrible horrible miss that this is okay
anyway so uh so thank you everybody so
much for watching this has been Sims for
I will get back into actually playing
the game in another episode down the
road because I took way too long trying
to X you put this [ __ ] together so thank
you again everybody for watching let me
know what you think in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
hey you're ready I smell bad I also have
to go to the bathroom don't mind the
owner